A friend of a friend of a friend attributes his beating stage 3 colon cancer by the supplement
Apaginid. So what are what are Apaginid's? Do you test for this? I typically don't test for
that. Apaginid's are flavonoids. I think they're I think they're in oregano. There's a high
amount of oregano. There's they're in onions. I think they're broccoli. They're in a lot of
your vegetables. So there are Apaginid's in your green drink. If you were going to do oregano,
you could use it for that. And maybe the the so it is a flavonoid. So whenever we talk about with
anybody asked questions about inflammation, I have inflammation. What should I do about that?
And I always talk about seems like almost every Zoom call we talk about the flavonoids. So your
typical flavonoids that you think of are curcumin, green tea extract, Boswellia,
Resveratrol. Those are your most powerful flavonoids. But there's a lot of different flavonoids
in vegetables. That's why I like the green drink because it's got such a mixture of different
vegetables and it's just a whole food product. That's why you should be your vegetables because
they have different things in it. They have a synergistic effect. Could you just take this product? Yes,
you could take that product too. But it is in the flavonoid category and it is highly anti-inflammatory,
corseted green tea extract. I said I think already white willow bark and sticky dental. All those
kind of things have flavonoids in it. So they're anti-inflammatory. So using any of those flavonoids
can be quite helpful for any inflammation. With any disease process there's inflammation and
certainly with cancer there's inflammation.